politics the final presidential debate
is tonight in nashville
plexiglas will divide president trump
and former vice president joe biden
tonight
there will also be a mute button to give
each candidate two minutes to speak
uninterrupted at the start of each topic
here's natalie brandt with a preview
former president barack obama held his
first major event for joe biden
yesterday
hello philadelphia while his former vice
president took a break from the campaign
trail to prepare for tonight's debate
with president trump with joe and kamala
at the helm
you're not going to have to think about
the crazy things they said
every day the current commander-in-chief
brushed off the attack at a rally in
north carolina
there was nobody that campaigned harder
for crooked hillary clinton
tonight the two candidates will be here
in nashville for the second and final
presidential debate
a cbs news poll found 69 percent of
viewers felt annoyed by the constant
interruptions in the first match-up
it was like two kindergartners going at
it many voters say their minds are made
up but still want to see a debate that's
focused on the issues
rather than the
the personal attacks that are going
president trump says he may interrupt
biden less and hopes he trips himself
up and is also expected to bring up
hunter biden's work overseas
the bidens got rich well north carolina
and
our country got robbed last night
national security officials announced
iran and russia obtained voter
registration data to try to influence
the election
the great women and men of the
intelligence community
caught this activity immediately you
should be confident
that your vote counts they accused iran
of imitating a right-wing group and
sending
emails to democratic voters that
threaten to come after them unless they
vote for president trump
natalie brand cbs news nashville
8 news now is your local election
headquarters we have extended coverage
and more updates for you on 8newsnow.com